es gibt kräfte versuchen so eine liebe
zwischen andere vermeintliche politische
elite und die breite bevölkerung nach ob
es muss in der schweiz eigentlich
mitglied
ich danke man ins zeit bestandteil vor
wahlen stimmen liegt bei uns in der
schweiz dass ich das lese privileg
also suchte einschnitt ist dass man sich
meistens mit sehr wenig vorteil trifft
dass man mit jedem raum kann reden und
gemeinsames ziel rang folge das ist
einzigartig und datteln dieses letzten
satz verteidiger und dann probiert die
zu motivieren politischen abstimmungen
waren als nicht mit dem bundes muss
entschieden werden
und ich werde mir nun mozart der kultur
dass sich das andere und mini stimmen
ist zum beispiel
[Musik]
analog so liegt ein jahr dass sie so
schnell nicht vergessen hat
heute auf den tag genau ein jahr vor den
wahlen hat sie ihren ersten auftritt als
neue generalsekretärin der cvp im
wahlkampf wird lucio eine zentrale rolle
spielen
[Musik]
bekommen zur begrüßung unserer neuen
generalsekretärin gina lisa sie ist in
einer cvp familien aufgewachsen das war
schon die grundvoraussetzung dass wir
sie zu eingraben haben und sie hat ja
für die cvp politisch engagiert herzlich
willkommen
wir freuen uns auf eine gute
zusammenarbeit und ich gebe die gerne
das wort
[Applaus]
stimme aus den jahren präsident stimmen
konzentrieren
regionale stationiert ich hätte es mir
nicht zu träumen gewagt dass ich eines
tages das heißt heute und hier vor ihnen
stehe
vor ihnen stehen da als ihre
generalsekretärin
wir haben großes vor in zwölf monaten
sind wahlen in wenigen wochen eine
bundesratswahl wir standen heute
lancieren heute eine volksinitiative und
auch mit der wahlkampagnen sind wir
schon unterwegs
ich freue mich unglaublich gemeinsam mit
ihnen diese aufgabe anzupacken und die
schweiz gemeinsam voranzubringen in
kolonialen platz bin ich bin leben als
zuvor hat und jetzt bin ich selbst
zerstört hat spaß kunst
das ist ja gut die hessische gute
startchancen
jetzt muss sich die cvp nur noch gehör
bei den wählern verschaffen
gleich nach der delegiertenversammlung
beginnt für gianna lucio der wahlkampf
auf der straße mit einer kostenbremse
für das gesundheitswesen gehen die
christdemokraten auf bilderjagd
der wähleranteil der cvp hat sich in den
letzten 20 jahren halbiert
helfen diese talfahrt zu bremsen das ist
die große aufgabe von gianna lucio im
kommenden jahr fdp kampagnenleiter
matthias leitner plant schon seit
monaten den wahlkampf er will die
parteimitglieder von tür zu tür schicken
das ist neu für die freisinnigen wäre
die erste sure league ziel für die
jetzige 70 wind durch die ganzen wir
machen abgestimmt sind nicht aufs
geratewohl sollen die fdp durch die
quartiere ziehen sondern von einer app
gesteuert dorthin wo am ehesten neue
wähler zu holen sind der datengestützte
wahlkampf ist in der schweiz angekommen
der bevölkerung vorstellen und schöpfen
lediglich 16,4 prozent welche
möglichkeit der digitalen wahlkampf so
wie sie war
[Musik]
um den dienst über wollen wie viel wie
vielen dass das dann auch weise liegt
dabei auf das mit 2000 trier 21
die ganze kraft der maßnahmen werden
verboten etwas verspätet kommt der serie
a zu schulung sie wird einer der ersten
sein die app gesteuert von tür zu tür
geht wie alle hier kandidiert sie für
den zürcher kantonsrat
danach will sie sich für den nationalrat
aufstellen lassen bevor die fdp ihre
neue app national einsetzt sollen die
zürcher kantonalpartei sie testen
vorerst noch als rollenspiel
und das hier bin ich das ich denke ja
ich bin gespannt jetzt im moment kann
ich ganz gewiss vertrieben
[Musik]
die acht monaten wählen die
schweizerinnen und schweizer ein neues
parlament
die fdp möchte gerne die zeit stärkste
partei werden im parlament also die sp
verdrängen im moment ist ein
kopf-an-kopf in der grüne steigflug hält
an 95 prozent würden derzeit gemäss
umfragen die svp nicht immer noch
deutlich vorn mit 27 prozent
wähleranteil
aber sie verliert gemäss umfrage 24
diana gutjahr hat etwas gegen berufs
parlamentarier im familieneigenen
metallbaubetrieb ist sie auf der suche
nach einem foto mit ihr will sie sich
als frau der wirtschaft zeigen die svp
nationalrätin ist vor zwei jahren ins
parlament nach gerutscht nun plant sie
minutiös die verteidigung ihres sitzes
wahlkampfleiter ist roland gutjahr
dianas vater werber stefan ströbele
hilft dem team gut jahr beim austeilen
einer mehrstufigen kampagne machen
das sind 6 sekundenbruchteil wo man die
wieder über bringen und den wir jetzt
noch viel nachsagen dass man sie dann
wieder
alle sind kompakt ich höre da so machen
hat er mit dem stoff machen kann hängt
und herrsche
klassische der hand habe und bin andere
muss immer wieder aufmache ihnen wird
von den heads dienen und den brink das
nicht recht ihnen eigentlich da wo man
es machen sehr sehr stark sein
unternehmen nun welches produkt ab riese
wenn du als portugiese durch die
extraprämie von schluss sein wenn der
kurs schon dafür tun dann zeigen die
überschüsse kommen und zeigen den erfolg
die ein produkt der versuch ist
lebenslust ich finde ich überhaupt nicht
als produkt da höre mich in arizona
winzen der durch ergänzte ich glaube
aber immer da wo man doch seht oder wahr
jetzt gehört durch diskussion dass ich
mich den so wären sie mich überhaupt
nicht stabil ich bin immer personen und
dass er immer wieder zusätzliches mein
kopf und mein name moderne stadt und ich
muss können die kinder stehen in der
dritten person und da ich mir immer ganz
wichtig
[Musik]
eine kleinigkeit fehlt noch die
nominierung doch das ist formsache
[Musik]
einstimmig zur kandidatin gekürt
doch der svp steht ein schwieriges jahr
bevor
ganz warten einige sich überhaupt nicht
sie vom 20
[Musik]
florence brennt seehofer hat sich den
richtigen wohnort ausgesucht von über
2000 schweizer gemeinden hat goldingen
vor vier jahren am zweitgrößten gewählt
jetzt will die grüne grenze ko für den
sprung in den nationalrat schaffen
brands ico verarbeitet teilzeit als
sekundarlehrerin in liestal die
demonstrationen der klima jugend haben
in der schweiz gerade erst begonnen
man kann vorerst nur ahnen wie sehr die
klimadebatte den schweizer wahlkampf
dominieren wird
florence bremse kupfer erwartet
parteikolleginnen und kollegen zu besuch
sie führt im moment gleich zwei
wahlkämpfe denn vor den eidgenössischen
stehen dieses jahr in baselland auch
noch kantonale wahlen an
das heißt das eben eine gute wahl
übrigens am samstag selbst peter wachsen
dort sicherlich sehr schmal so eine
schrieb aktionären bis jetzt weg macht
aber es geht darum dass man leute da
schreiber aus dem weiteren umfeld und
nicht unbedingt sympathisanten sind und
mitglieder sind für die kalter winter
sondern einfach danke die könnten uns
stehen die grünen starten mit besten
voraussetzungen ins wahljahr
doch die chance dass florence prinzip
ufer im oktober nationalrätin wird
scheint im moment noch klein
die fdp führte sie regie an die
rheinstraße im zürcher kreis 2 als gast
ist parteipräsidentin petra gössi dabei
mitmachen politikers gehört mit dazu und
interessante gespräche
die syrische hat kaum chancen auf die
wahl ins kantonsparlament trotzdem setzt
sie viel zeit ein für ihre partei
ich möchte gern zwei die frage stelle
zur politik was sie beschäftigt und so
viel dass für den häusern oti zu machen
das ist ein problem
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
problem auslöser
aus worten sollen schließlich daten
werden
ja und jetzt richtig los
[Musik]
beim tür zu tür wahlkampf im zürcher
kreis 2 erscheint das thema umwelt auf
dem radar der fdp und wird bis zu den
wahlen nicht mehr verschwinden
im bereich umwelt und klima brauche es
konkrete praxistaugliche und griffige
massnahmen für unser land in den letzten
monaten nur die hydra wunsch unterwegs
war immer wieder heftig umweltpolitikern
gesprochen
die begrünung des parteipolitischen fdp
terrace löst parteiintern nicht nur
applaus auf petra g sieg macht ernst
ihre umweltpolitische kehrtwende soll
anders als in früheren es ist der erste
mai tag der arbeit anna galati bereitet
das herzstück des sozialdemokratischen
wahlkampfs vor die basis kampagne
sie ist eine so genannte kempenerin das
ist am anfang so für schwierige lage
noch schwierig drei schnitt zwischen
berufs kontext mit dem kolleg aber also
kameras wirtschaft durch das
telefonieren und du bist gut wenn er
krank und schloss das werk du hast dich
angemalt einmal für die zweite fünfte
anstieg
stehen wir nicht ein und sondere obwohl
ich jetzt machen und will ich finde das
mit bestimmten mega mega wichtig ist und
das ist halt im alltag für viele
interessant ist und ich glaube da könnte
teil dazu beitragen dass es vielleicht
besser wird und dass ihr stimmrecht
worden amazon im gegensatz zu vielen
anderen hier hat anna dass die schon
erfahrung mit kampagnen jobs 38 frauen
und männer werden von der parteileitung
für ihre arbeit in den kantonen geschult
vier tage büffeln im ausbildungscamp
[Musik]
[Applaus]
parteipräsident christian levrat kommt
persönlich um die kampagne auf das
gemeinsame ziel einzuschwören
das ist etwas das nicht begleitet zeigt
zehn jahre dieser überzeugung dass wir
näher zu den leuten kommen dass die zeit
und wo man einfach ein stolzer aufstellt
und wartet bis die leute auf uns
zukommen dass dieser zeit zu einer
langsamen vorweisen wenn sie wirklich
leute erreichen wollen dann müssen sie
zu ihnen entweder direkt oder sonst per
telefon weil es ermöglicht ihm eine viel
breitere anzahl von leuten zu treffen
und wenn es dringend nötig dass wir
einen aktiven und erfolgreichen
wahlkampf machen
die sp hat als erster schweizer partei
auf diese amerikanische wahlkampf
methode gesetzt das brachte ihr vor vier
jahren ein extra prozent wähleranteil
diesen erfolg will die sp nun
übertreffen anna galati und ihrer
kampagne kolleginnen und kollegen haben
fünf monate zeit um das gesteckte ziel
zu erreichen
heute will die anna lucia die
nationalrats kandidatinnen und
kandidaten ihrer partei fit für den
wahlkampf machen
lucio spielt die kritische frau auf dem
marktplatz
wir wollen eine schweiz in der
gesundheit für alle zugänglich und
bezahlbar ist oder der finden wie das
berühmte und mit probieren jetzt
komplexität der politik vor dass cvp
einfach darstellen will
das ist so wenn man selber hierbei will
den haag einfache antwort amerika
einfache lösung parat das ist logisch
und richtig so und das unterschreibe
darum so wichtig jetzt sagen danke für
deine schöne highlights
danke für diana gutjahr hat schon ein
vip frühstück und einen halben
arbeitstag hinter sich
jetzt fährt sie zu ihrer wahlkampf
eröffnung nach amriswil
[Musik]
das im prinzip bei der wärme sind und
den kunden daraufhin von ihr und wenn er
nach einer unruhigen
[Musik]
darüber informiert dass sie doch alle
sind und dementsprechend freut sich
elisabeth trotzdem regenschirm davos
international jana gut ja ich finde das
super median hast du video im wahlkampf
dass die linke wisse was er sage es
heißt für die wir auch dass es braucht
und das wäre sensationell für mich ist
doch wohl traurigste nur das glück lebte
dann heißt gewählt ist mit 128 stimmen
vor augen hat seine gute
ja da viel franz andreas und applaus von
der un vorliegen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
definiert einer von morgen hatte
wahrscheinlich wenig ganz darauf
gewettet dass die fdp den sitz verliert
klimademonstration als musiker für
jugendliche zürich und jahrhundert steht
die zürcher bürgerlichen wird der
wahltag hingegen zu ende war
eine woche nach der fdp-niederlage bei
den zürcher wahlen heute hätte der tag
sein sollen an dem des ihre kreation
nationalratskandidatin gekürt wird
doch sie steht nicht auf der liste
fr nicht wie man muss es einfach
wir sind und was genau dazu geführt dass
hoffe dass es das gesetz vor
findungskommission wird wieder
kontrollieren nord der
delegiertenversammlung irgendwelche
gründe warum aber bestimmt die personen
auf der liste nicht und nicht auf der
liste ist und du verliebst du bist ja
also ich macht haben hält rußig ich
meine gerne auf der realistisch sie ich
bin ich bei operativ findungskommission
wahnsinnig schwierige aufgabe und ich
wollte auch phoenix kommission danke
dass sie paaren gemacht habe bitte ich
weiß einfach nur irgendwie vergessen
man hat ja eigentlich mal stoppte die
papiere so laut dass hinzukommt
frauenfeld langfristig sehr wenige
frauen haben würde wenn ich genug meint
art und weise was das mit musik uff
stocker und dann doch mindestens täter
muss irgendwie nun nicht erfülle
was einfach die linien zu überstehen
wenigstens die junge frau bekommt machen
ich kann dem nur zustimmen
ich hoffe die stadt persönlich andere
präferenzen aber nicht stand das immer
ehrlich egal ob otto c&a peek wird ihnen
brachte anatolischen ablehnend viel für
andere kommunen mannschaft mit denen von
hand mehr frei sind speerspitze von den
bürgerlichen im content serien und ich
glaube dass sich die zeiten geändert und
sichergestellt dass man interne kämpfe
spielen und dann dort mit nur wo es eine
politische gange sind auf besserung
ob er der liebste mit zu stehen es als
bitte mit dem bau zattoo bekundet wer
hier liegt der ablehnt soll es ebenfalls
bezüge mit dem walter
sie haben
der rathenower zwar nächster
zurückstufen mit 158 9 und 12
enthaltungen
die zürcher fdp liste bleibt unverändert
für diese steuer ist der wahlkampf
beendet noch bevor er richtig begonnen
hat
[Musik]
trotzdem passiert ist war das irgendwie
und berufsalltag nachmittag meter langes
schweiz aktuell extra toto sind
bürgerliche walbaum um das mächtige
ganze sitzt für die grünen gemacht haben
auf kosten der svp gange die grünen
können am meisten zugewinne verzeichnen
die kantonsparlamente werden generell
deutlich grüner und deutlich linke
fraktions ausflug der grünen in beide
basel gastgeberin florence prinzip ufer
ist frisch wiedergewählte landrätin mit
einem glanzresultat jetzt geht um den
nationalrat die bisherige grüne
nationalrätin maya graf will ständerätin
werden
schafft sie das würde bremse kupfer in
den nationalrat nachrutschen
jetzt kommen sie mit dem green eggs
es ist überhaupt noch nichts gewonnen
zeile erholen ich kann es ich kann es
sagen es ist schwieriger meinen wenn man
den rückenwind hat als wenn man gegen
den wind dann kämpft weil man die gefahr
sie auch lässig zu werden ich danke euch
für euren einsatz ich zähle auf euch
und auf bewegung immer noch auf straßen
und das ist nicht das bild anschließend
notwendigen presseamt sich das heißt der
letzte wahlkampf ohne rechnung 22 10
euro sogar bis auf
so wie der letzte ball srg und den
schluss ziehen
bahnfahren ohne große ganze kompanie
sache einfach
[Musik]
es ist frühsommer camperin anna galati
steckt mitten in der ersten phase des sp
basis wahlkampfes der grund warum das
mit das macht einfach ganz kurzfristig
event wieder mit elite dialog
kommunikation nach kontext und glied und
sonst entscheider es gott ist ein
monitor ist über zinke also wie man mit
der er häufig die beine des die welle
des psp sondern nur wenn wirklich wissen
was sie interessiert das ist ja der
grund warum das nun mit allen reden
also mir hat nicht vorgefertigt die
nächste mit wem das mit dem ko retten
wir können die insassen nur weil die
städte sind derlei und wachse dem konto
ist ihm aber auch durch das drehen sind
darum gewachsen
also muss ein relatives großes team das
ist wichtig ist heute viel spaß und
aufeinander abgestimmt und mit
gesprächsleitfaden ausgerüstet klopfen
sp mitglieder die luzerner innenstadt ab
wie zeugen jehovas einfach überall
und wenn man drückt doch nicht fragt wer
ist das da hätten sie aber ich weiß
nicht so gestehen muss dass verschiedene
klar nach als 15 16
anna galati trägt die verantwortung für
die tür zu tür aktion in luzern
campaigner sind die einzig bezahlten msp
basis wahlkampf insgesamt 30 freiwillige
sind an diesem samstag in luzern
unterwegs
[Musik]
im frühjahr auch kontakt zu der lügt
oder die stadt ordnet über gesundheit
zwei fragen stellen und das klima und
arbeitswelt und ausgesagt
das thema rückt in der hauptsache
lohngleichheit oder sexismus bekannt war
dass frauen männer zweier moment
geretteten situationen
was ist wichtig dass jetzt erst sechs
ismus debatte bin laden fühle ich mich
persönlich bin ich jetzt nicht betroffen
aber so anderem aufgespürt wo immer
weiteres thema ist das war mir schon
wichtig dass man den immer mit
aufmerksamkeit arbeitet überlegt richtig
viel los war heute auf schweizer
strassen und plätzen an diesem 40 und
juni allein vier bis fünftausend frauen
versammelten sich am vormittag vor dem
bundeshaus zu demonstrieren heute für
die vereinbarkeit von beruf und familie
wohl gleichheit für sehr vieles in der
schweiz beteiligten sich hunderttausende
frauen am nationalen streiktag
diana gutjahr geht nicht an den
frauenstreik sie geht wandern
das st galler tagblatt hat drei
ostschweizer prominente zur bergtour
eingeladen
für die webseite der zeitung wird der
ganze tag live getickert für gut ja eine
willkommene plattform
die menschen gerne vater habe zeige dort
immerhin und den kulissen schon darum
bin ich stand damit die zweite offen
sitze ich denke aber dass moderator
marco fritsche und hackbrett spieler
nicolas sind gut jahrs weggefährten auf
dem programm steht die königs tour 1 80
kilometer langer zweitägiger im alpstein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ob sie bei
solange
[Musik]
nach 30 kilometern auf und ab in den
appenzeller bergen kommen bei diana
gutjahr zur müdigkeit noch knieschmerzen
dazu gutjahr muss die wanderung nach
einem tag abbrechen
die wählergunst will hart erkämpft sein
um den live-ticker kontaktdaten auch
immer wieder mal wie viele tests
workshops es hat sich sehr viel dafür
interessiert und über den ganzen tag
verteilt sind doch einige leser
interessiert und 30.000 besucher hat der
live ticker am ersten tag ein ausflug
der sich für diana gutjahr trotz
schmerzen gelohnt hat
die schweiz vor dem wahlherbst im
oktober wird das parlament neu gewählt
laut gegenwärtigen trends deutet alles
auf einen linksrutsch in für die fdp
zeigt das wahlbarometer einen
abwärtstrend der fdp schadet offenbar
ihre klimadebatte sich eine allfällige
neupositionierung der fdp puncto
klimapolitik positiv auf die wahlen im
herbst auswirken würde ist fraglich
matthias leitner steht mit der fdp nicht
dort wo er gerne möchte
knapp drei monate vor den wahlen treibt
das thema klima die freisinnigen mehr um
als ihnen lieb ist
ich glaube schon dass die gangs sie
zuvor von der klimafrage madrid hat
greifenstein die liberale lösungen
können bietet der stars hat dazu geführt
dass wichtige fragen könnte kann sich
die antwort alternative
[Musik]
treffen in einer zürcher werbeagentur
hier bespricht das fdp wahlkampf team
die nächsten schritte der kampagne und
analysiert die lage im detail ich gehe
schnell die liste durch gesundheit
ich gehe im moment gemäss gut
informierten kreisen davon aus dass die
prämien nicht so stark steigen werden
und mit nicht so stark meine ich
irgendwo etwas um die zwei prozent herum
vielleicht sogar tiefer migration wenn
die zahlen so bleiben und die diskussion
weiter auf dem feld ist soll man sogar
ein asylzentrum schließen
dann hat die svp in diesem wahlkampf
langsam wirklich ein massives problem
für uns sind das gute neuigkeit
gegenüber der sp müssen wir über
altersvorsorge wirtschaft und
bilateralen diskutieren klima ich glaube
dort würden sie sich gern mit uns
streiten weil dann wären würden sie
stattfinden das problem ist sie finden
auf diesem thema schlicht und einfach
nicht statt
wir möchten nicht nur länger auf diesem
thema seien aktiv glaubwürdigkeit haben
wir bei den einem themen autos vor
sauber gewirtschaftet und dort haben wir
auch keinen internen
in dem graben gegen wenn wir uns zu
stark auf die auf die umweltpolitik
konzentrieren dann werden wir immer auch
die die die beiden seiten innerhalb der
partei aufeinander los hetzen ich fände
es viel wichtiger dass wir jetzt ein
neues thema bespielen können in diesem
bereich auch ich finde das auch die
immer noch wichtig diese generation und
frau gibt es müssen wir aufnehmen
ich glaube das ist wirklich etwas sowie
antworten liefern müssen
und das ist dann nämlich auch dass dafür
die altersvorsorge aber damit bespielen
wieder andere themen wie kann nicht nur
auf einem thema jetzt wird man sagen wie
das vierte vier monate lang besetzt
besorgen braucht die schule
stattgefunden und jetzt wir müssen
weitergehen und wir haben es unsere
antworten
viereinhalb stunden dauert es bis alle
themen besprochen sind
ich bin froh im ritterhaus trainer
diskutieren
dazu muss das ganze sätze lang und den
mooren das ganz analog per protocol
reisen und dann wird der ein oder andere
für die denn so wie sein trainer
entscheiden können aber hübsch nicht
fertig auch wenn die fdp das thema klima
nun gerne abhaken möchte
es bleibt wahlkampf thema nummer eins
[Musik]
der wahlkampf für die wahlen im herbst
läuft unter anderem auch mit plakaten
wie die andere partei schweiz zu
zerstören
die partei macht mitten im wirbel um das
apfel plakat besucht diana gutjahr die
delegiertenversammlung der svp das
plakat hat die thurgauerin in die
bredouille gebracht
strategische funktion die keine
operativen funktionen als nationalrätin
und der ich hoffe sagt themen
auseinandersetzen dürfen wäre eine
bildung
so richtig eng
[Musik]
[Applaus]
viel symbolik gibt am partei fest und
harte worte
die svp will ihre basis sieben wochen
vor den wahlen nach woking
wie wollen sie und jetzt bin ich bei
diesem abgeblockt wie wurden sie eine
saison bereit die die anderen parteien
machen angefangen mit verfassungsbruch
bei der massenzuwanderung nichtumsetzung
krimineller ausländer verschieben von
allen relevanten geschäften auf nach den
wahren um vorher so zu tun als ob
wie wollen sie eine solche sauerei beste
darstellen auf mit dem apfel der von
morgen an gefressen wurde wie es braucht
uns in diesem wahlkampf weil die
vereinigten linken und netten uns
zerstören wollen unter gütiger mithilfe
der vierte macht im staat
und da aber nun gegensteuer zu geben
gestand heldt
diana gutjahr versucht sich aus der
apfel plakat diskussion möglichst
herauszuhalten
die gespräche bleiben unversehrt
man verstand sich nie zu
bis 24
die schlechten umfragewerte der svp an
diesem samstag in sattel kein thema hier
herrscht optimismus zwangsläufig denn
anders lässt sich ein wahlkampf nicht
bestreiten
anna galati ist kein morgen mensch doch
der kampagnen job frisst viel zeit sich
abzugrenzen von der arbeit fällt schwer
ich bin froh ist nun zehnmaligen und
genehmigt augen mit der auch das
veränderte wenn man das so genau
seine günstige gar nicht dass es so
heftige schlachter oder das sagt es mir
gemacht dass er nicht so schätzt der
kleine tricks die motivationskraft
andere unbedingt und besonders mit
150000 menschen will die sp im vorfeld
der wahlen das gespräch führen
kein berlinerin anna galatis hauptjob
ist für diese freiwilligenarbeit
parteimitglieder zu begeistern dass man
auch so viel wie möglich länder touren
mobilisieren damit ihnen via liter im
schulwald und ich hatte gäste zum die
frage ob du dich endlich vorstellen
mit kilian koch leitet galati den basis
wahlkampf in luzern zweimal im monat
treffen sie sich mit containern anderer
kantone zum austausch anna und ihre
kollegen müssen gegenüber der nationalen
und regionalen leitungen rechenschaft
darüber ablegen ob sie auf kurs sind
sie ist überhaupt machen und sehr windig
kuchen und damit die motivation slams
[Gelächter]
das mittel zur rückseite aktivität wird
gesagt man sich ingo freyer rezepte
waren gemacht mit kleinen abstrichen
sind hier alle im zeitplan
florence brandhofer und tochter nuria
sind unterwegs an die stein stoß
schweizer meisterschaften in ihrem
nachbardorf ein guter monat vor den
wahlen ist jeder tag ein wahlkampfgag
auch ständeratskandidatin meyer graf ist
hier
sie ist nervös denn im vergleich zur
konkurrenz haben die grünen viel weniger
wahlplakate aufgehängt
[Musik]
weyergraf hat heute noch ganz andere
herausforderungen zu bewältigen
auch sie muss steinstoßen für einen news
beitrag zum ständeratswahlkampf das
steinstoßen experiment dauert länger als
geplant brennt siegufer und graf müssten
jetzt zusammen weiter zum nächsten
termin
die freitags runde gespräche das erstes
über die wahlkampagne der cvp die diese
woche zu reden gegeben hat die cvp hat
stets betont dass sie im wahljahr 2009
10 ganz auf den digitalen kanal setzen
und die partei die macht ja auch google
fall werbung mit politikerinnen und
politikern der konferenz die reaktionen
kamen schnell innert kurzer zeit wurde
der hashtag cvp fell zum meist
getwitterten schlagwort der schweiz
[Musik]
anna lucia am tag nach dem sturm
unzählige anrufe hat sie gestern zur cvp
google kampagne erhalten
jetzt trifft sie sich mit martin kühlen
sie zur nachbesprechung er ist chef von
enigma der digitalagentur welche die
kampagne umgesetzt hat aber das müssen
der 11
ich sagen und eigentlich hätte ich den
chef oder gar nicht zugesagt ziemlich
ziemlich geile aktion
mit parteilos teilzeit wenn wir das
machen wir jetzt ganz gut in aktion wohl
provoziert wo viele cvp typisches
schwierigkeit her und hat erkannt dass
sie ermittle partei ist gar nicht
provozieren lässt sich das thema gemacht
aber nicht der typische europa cvp die
zeigen wie sie nicht so brav die
maschine am gleichen morgen bei der fdp
hier hat die cvp kampagne für ärger
gesorgt dass ihr bistro wertheim areal
ist also heute zwei wochenende zieht die
zeitraum eine genau gewusst was aber
schon die alarmglocken geläutet will
sich seite die arg und mit mit nicks cvp
brender der website dass sie schon mal
forum startet parteien nicht mit ihrem
namen hervor das als salat ist für mich
völlig no go das ist eine spirale wo
meine abtritt wie weit darf magath
vivitek gott andre mcgee
ich habe mich an das problem briten und
iren das problem damit von der
ausgerechnet von rapper das gehöre oder
angeschossen
wo hätte meinen sie hätten stemmen
auf dem cvp generalsekretariat versucht
man derweil einzuschätzen wie sich der
aufruhr um die kampagne in den nächsten
tagen und wochen auswirken wird
zwei wochen wird das ganze wateten durch
das haben
es ist nur fdp svp sp vom gerät ab
wie ist es ihnen gelungen ist so so der
despina als kläger gestern die große
endbericht kennedy oder wo ist natürlich
dennoch sehr sehr viel aufmerksamkeit
aber hat auch sehr viel gegenwind gehabt
und müssen als partei hat nicht so
gewöhnt in der gegend mit mit
überzeugung und das ist jetzt wirklich
das wunder geschafft
in den nächsten tag und ich glaube vor
daran herum und die gal nicht gerade wir
müssen danach noch einmal ein paar und
ein paar überlegungen machen apa
telefongespräche machen ein paar mails
machen und schauen wir mit das
hermetische reihen schließen können
es ist intensiv und sicherheit
auch nicht immer alles ist das gerät
einfach umdreht
dreht und toni wir probieren
zum der job gut königsmacher besucher
bis die stadt mit abstand auf platz zu
wenig gedanken mitmachen
das fehlt im moment
am tag der nationalen klima demo in bern
macht anna die in luzern basis wahlkampf
für die sp für die erste grosse
schlussmobilisierung vor den wahlen
erwartet gallati mehrere dutzend
parteimitglieder deren job telefonieren
diaz wähler rufen leute an die in
irgendeiner form schon mal mit der
partei zu tun hatten und ihre nummer
hinterlassen haben
ein streng gehütete datensatz der hier
genutzt wird
[Musik]
zur gleichen zeit bereitet sich florence
brennt sie koffer in bern auf die klima
demo vor 80.000 leute erwarten die
organisatoren für brands seehofer der
vorläufige höhepunkt des wahljahres
zurück in luzern bei der sp des
sinfonischen telefon samstag zu machen
und sind eigentlich oder der
entscheidungsshow ist sie mir ein kunde
des fluchtweges oder das brauchte die
triftstraße und sg talle thun liegt gar
noch die straßen in einem kontext
aussagen aufs neue mitglieder
und wie ist das eigentlich für eine
konsequente klimapolitik bucher links
lutz bin ich überzeugt macht aber und
das ist wie gehabt ein teil mehr als
probieren zum links rutschen zur klima
politik des anderen
[Musik]
eine der größten demonstrationen die es
in bern je gegeben hat kündigt an die
grüne welle wird bis zu den wahlen
weiter rollen
[Applaus]
großartig was jetzt hier und das ist das
was heute derweil in luzern bei der sp
solche nummern würden blockiert sagt
anna galati und wer angerufen werde habe
anrecht auf volle transparenz woher die
partei die nummer hat 560 anrufe sind
das tagesziel der sp luzern galati ist
mit dem zwischenstand zufrieden
[Musik]
der sp luzern geht es so gut wie noch
nie
historischer rekord stand an mitgliedern
und wählern dank basis kampagnen auf
kommunaler und kantonaler ebene
nun könnte gar ein zweiter nationalrat
sitzt drin liegen die kante kreuzlingen
hat diana gut ja zu einem hearing
eingeladen
mit auf dem podium sp
ständeratskandidatin nina schleifer
gefragt ist dann aber vor allem gut ja
[Musik]
wer seit den oder reha behauptet dass
zwei frauen oder zweimal bundesrat
möchte dadurch die reds gleich gut die
intensiven mann und frau 61 mittel
wirtschaft war wie tief ist ja der
industrie andere umwelt schützen
das buch beides aber im moment einfach
aufpassen dass man immer eine heikkinen
arendt und den auf einmal bisher
ausblendet dort nicht richtig verstanden
hat sie der klimawandel verändert als
hype also als trend bezeichnet
wie lässt sich von null auf hundert frau
ist als hätte die schwere technische
oder auch sehr klug gemacht dass jung
smart click deutschland einnahmen nrw
dass ich rede tour nichtsdestotrotz von
motorrädern
dieses thema am montag nicht in
extremismus in betrieb in bremen immer
zuverlässige politik machen umwelt der
mensch nach dummen mit gegenwind hat
jana gute aber den gymnasiasten
gerechnet von der heftigkeit wurde sie
allerdings überrascht
richtig ich habe ja zwei stunden hat
wenn sie glaubt zehn minuten vor der
vorstellung geht es mal ist da viel
vielleicht natürlich ventus in betrieb
unser wunsch und entreißt ihr habt das
er und zweck dieser industrie und im
quer- und inkrementelle volk ist völlig
klar
zwei fragen 1
logistiker wie verletzten ausstaffiert
bedrückt mich immer noch ein klima das
problem
das sieht das sieht eine marke
geschaffen und die bürger da ist einfach
zeit vergessen
ja
anna lucia arbeitet im moment sieben
tage die woche es ist session die letzte
bevor die karten neu gemischt werden
berlin
die physik priester war mit notfällen
jetzt den kopf noch fürs kerngeschäft
frei zu haben
also gesetze zu beschließen ist
schwierig es zeigt sich dass
das fehlen seines stars nicht warum das
noch nicht gemacht und somit nicht
vergessen dass natürlich die sache
entschieden hat ich wahrgenommen weil
niemals grabstellen
das muss alles noch schneller
es muss noch einiges nicht mit den
hinterrädern
das ist sehr sehr intensiv und einfach
auf das teppichgeschäft jetzt endlich
oder legislaturen und entfacht haben
soll
und das ist schwierig
bei
nach der session hängt gianna lucio noch
einmal zehn stunden arbeit an
sie fährt nach chur und zurück lucio
kandidiert im kanton graubünden für den
nationalrat als listen füllen
das alles zusammen ist am limit des
machbaren
[Musik]
mit der lassen
in sachen zu holen
in dem die sessions ostblock mit der bis
vor allem das wird
britische pfund
und ich das sowieso
ja entsprechen ich glaube nicht dass sie
das du hast die macht an die klappe
könntest der nummer gut machen weil es
einfach es ist es wo sehr stark
konsumiert das konsumieren mini energie
mehr als mensch bedingt natürlich bitter
aber es braucht möglichst nicht 20
jahren machen
das letzte im letzten york lebt
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum letzten
wahlbarometer ford eigentlichen wollen
es könnte sich für schweizer
verhältnisse im nationalen einiges
gelingen
profi quad dann wird schon how klau
gewinner gibt es nur zwei die grünen und
grünliberalen erstaunlich bei der fdp im
gegensatz zur letzten umfrage verliert
sie wieder fdp kampagnenleiter matthias
leitner weiß noch nicht was ihn erwartet
er erhält das wahlbarometer in diesem
moment - 12
das wahlkampfteam fdp-generalsekretär
samuel land kommt zur lagebesprechung
beim forschen torgau
das mittel das mir erscheint ist mir
herrn kreil indizien auf nationaler
ebene ist sexy bürgerbrief über feedback
aus der kandidaten oder so sehen ist wo
das dass es einen massiven abbau an
dreht die richtige es verwegen also
schon meint die botschaft muss das mit
einem schumacher ja quasi 20 minuten
mutiger
er starb zwei tage später platziert die
fdp ein inserat auf der frontseite von
20 minuten für knapp 200000 franken
etwa 80.000 franken haben gut dass in
den wahlkampf investiert und viel zeit
ihre wähler mobilisiert gut ja heute in
der hintersten ecke des kantons thurgau
am herbstmarkt in fischingen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so läuft die schlussmobilisierung bei
der essenzen tour in der luzerner
innenstadt zwei tage vor den wahlen
hier habe
was musste starten
galatis kampagnen job ist beendet
trotzdem ist sie noch für die partei
unterwegs
[Musik]
schneider
ich bin ganz herausnehmen
der anzug macht
so dem moment das los
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht wen ich jetzt mal so
lange drauf habe
[Musik]
verbunden aber immer wieder mal eine
nacht oder einige man sagen ist also
herzlich willkommen fühlt sich wohl im
blick dies zu organisieren
doch mit wahlkampfchef und social media
moderatorin einem fdp mann matthias
leitner hat auch am wahltag volles
programm
doch eigentlich ist ihm nicht zum lachen
zumute
aus den kantonen gibt es erste schlechte
nachrichten der demokratie cvp
generalsekretär in china lucius auf das
schlimmste vorbereitet sich gegen aussen
nichts anmerken lassen lautet die devise
kurz vor 3 uhr erste lagebesprechung im
bundeshaus
die meisten konnten nicht starten wird
das befürchtete debakel scheint fürs
erste abgewendet
im baselbiet gibt es erste hinweise
darauf dass die grünen an diesem tag
alle erwartungen übertreffen werden
florians prinzip ufer ist mit
freundinnen unterwegs nach liestal an
den eigenen sitz wagt sie noch nicht zu
glauben
lampe
auch die luzerner sp macht sich bereit
für einen langen wahltag die ersten
neuigkeiten vermeintlich gut
[Musik]
es könnte also lud jetzt verdammt
bei diana gutjahr im thurgau
auch hier vorerst gute neuigkeiten
jetzt wieder ausland spitzenschwinger
york support aus dem bett wieder an
ihren zähnen der mensch immer gemacht
wahlkampfleiter roland gutjahr fügte
wie hoch sind die drei einig
florence prinzip hofer kommt im rathaus
[Musik]
und da habe sie die erste nationale
hochrechnung von der eidgenössischen
wahlen 2009
man könnte schon sagen es handelt sich
um einen grünen monsun sap verliert 0,1
prozent zu
zwölf unternehmen 2k und uri
seine botschaft sehe aber ich glaube es
lohnt sich nicht um
also es wird nicht aufgehen also man die
die erstaunt da muss man selbst trägt
somit zur selben frage schafft
interpretation der geschichte da gibt es
nur ein
der wahltag geht dem höhepunkt entgegen
elefantenrunde
[Musik]
die jüngsten habe ich fast den
diskussionen
die cvp bleibt stabil dort gerhard
pfister ist immer noch vorsichtig
ein bisschen
das darf schon gespannt wer sich
nein
von gerrit große stapfen etwas
mitbekommen
die aktion ist noch zu nehmen
so wahrscheinlich sagen profi geschafft
mit dem namen szenarien gut können
einfach in alle köpfe von den armen
durch und in anderen bis wir das
realisieren
frauenfeld diana gutjahr verfolgt die
verluste der svp in der übrigen schweiz
[Musik]
thomas müller um die max
helmut schafft
6 die damen und herren drei monate lang
gewartet und ist der feine sache vor der
svp gewählt sind die beiden bisherigen
frauen die auch noch gut ja und werner
herzog
[Applaus]
gutjahr schafft die wieder mit dem
besten resultat im kanton thurgau
[Musik]
florence brennt seehofer kennt ihr
resultat noch nicht zweiter platz bei
den grünen im kanton baselland und maya
graf steht im zweiten wahlgang für den
ständerat als klare favoritin
florians prinzip was einzug in den
nationalrat ist so gut wie sicher
mit 80
florence prinzip koffer hat heute rollt
lingen mit ihrem resultat von der
zweitgrössten zur grünsten gemeinde der
schweiz gemacht
[Musik]
enttäuschung bei anna galati aus dem 2
luzerner sp nationalrat zieht wird
nichts
kam ich schon zufrieden sie mit diesem
resultat um 280 liste stimmen nicht
lange für eine zweite sind zwar das
ergebnis and gun zu rufen wenn die
rallye schaffen kann das ist eine enorme
eine enorme aber turnier gleich scheint
danke viermal alten ruft straße in im
persönlichen umfeld und die das gesicht
erkennen und sich für die
sozialdemokratie danke filme
aber es hat nicht lohnt glauben auch
eine stunde also ich meine max
erinnerungslücken
wenn es auf insgesamt über eine optimale
abstimmung der kv mittlerer einkommen
und ich glaube das hat das essener
zentrum bin ich mir ganz schlecht und
haben das lenkte management
fehler wie bei der fdp will keine
feierlaune aufkommen wie nichts gekommen
um euch mein herzliches dankeschön zu
sagen wirklich den super einsatz der nie
gemacht hat und jetzt weit noch schön
ihr könnt doch erst wurden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für tanna lucio ist der wahltag beendet
und mit ihm ihr erstes jahr als
generalsekretär in der cvp